l'accueil que je suis toujours le cheval
dont ces questions carter débat dans la
salle à manger
merci d'être là vous aurez alors
question 4/3
oui vous les connais pas bien sûr alors
que c'est une question bonjour je
m'appelle françoise on me dit que votre
émission est super j'ai essayé de la
regarder mais je n'y comprends rien
c'est qui le pakistanais qui sont
partout c'est une question qui revient
souvent françoise de quoi parle notre
émission alors je vais essayer de vous
résumer un peu le pakistanais qui sont
partout c'est cyril addenda animateur
producteur et danseurs qui dansent à
l'antenne mais aussi pendant les pubs la
plupart du temps ils sont aussi boy
bertrand chamerois tout de suite les
ringards dans la semaine
obama
hahahaha
oui ça veut dire ces choses comme les
gars qui sue droite est venu pour gras
gay non non moi je suis vraiment venu
que pour donc ça j'ai pas d'os et de la
semaine la face à lyon j'ai même pas
parler me suis rendu dans la danse un
bon j'ai arrêter là car la suite n'était
pas difficile mais tout ce que je peux
dire c'est que tous les deux enfin bon
donc cyril danse mais il chante aussi
oui en fait si nous complexe car il a
tous les talents et le public l'adorent
regardez le quand il entonne a capella
du michel sardou le feeling qu'il est
avec ses spectateurs quand il leur tend
le micro c'est impressionnant bal à
pékin où les ongles ou
la piste
bigard à la tristesse il ya ce qu'on
appelle une osmose avait le don de nous
mettre en valeur mais je sais ce que je
peux je vais vous excuser parce que tout
ça c'est pas la faute de cyril amer
selon lui le problème c'est notre public
qui avons eu est de très mauvaise
qualité nord
alors isolé c'est pas en vous montrant
qu'on va vous faire progresser au début
ils étaient concentrés professionnels
maintenant ils viennent juste pour
déconner regardez je vous ai fait une
petite compil de nos spectateurs
regarder en bas à droite à votre
disposition un jeu je vais dire qu'un
retard et je pense qu'ils jouent
beaucoup les rats j luc lemoine alizés
c'est pas sûr ils vont amener la piscine
je complète
oui enfin tout en finesse nom est fausse
le garçon il faut le savoir il ne vient
dans l'émission que pour faire des
grimaces
d'ailleurs il est revenu la semaine
dernière
il est drôle mais je pense qu'il a un
stock parce qu'il peut pas s'en empêcher
regarder encore aller on a le public
qu'on mérite
pourtant il ya plein de choses
intéressantes dans notre émission déjà
ya thierry moreau thierry moreau le
journaliste rigolo qui à rire de deux
chevaux ça arrive mais c'est pas fait
exprès un des deux shows vous savez ces
vieilles voitures qui avaient du mal à
démarrer
balou rire de thierry c'est pareil le
rire le plus intelligent de départ et
métiers rien ne fait pas que rire il
sent aussi des vannes parfois des bonnes
mais la spa dans cette émission
ouais taxi obligé eric notre chauffeur
de salle à préparer notre public en
amont attention le cri de désespoir du
jour
l'épousé de terry série si vraiment tu
te poses la question peux tu expliquer
il faut le reconnaître
thierry temps beaucoup atteint rarement
la cible mais quand même souvent content
lui comme ici
alors deuxième but l'a fait
elle est grise moi ce que j'aime c'est
noté très mal et ça te fait rire les
batteries et l'autre qui suis bien
content lui eric est toujours aussi
amoureuse de jean michel puisque même
quand il ne ressemble à rien il le
trouve beau honnêtement c'est pas un
mythe déplacent même avec question la
paix sont ils enfin ça se voit pas trop
quoi
gareth pugh
allez
je ne sais pas aujourd'hui l'armée c'est
vraiment excusé des hommes est classé
jean-michel c'était lignon impossible si
jean michel est habillé en écho ces
sites à cause d'un pari perdu on s'en
souvient c'était pour danse avec les
stars
justement christophe carrière lui
c'était madonna à un pari gonflé que
christophe a pu tenir grâce au soutien
de tous il est dégueulasse début mars
ils me dégoûtent faut dire est un vrai
coeur qui veut qu il croit qu'il est
bonne j'ai pas envie de [ __ ]
excuse elle excusée alors la mort accusé
nommément mais j'aime les coulisses sont
très forts il se passe beaucoup de
choses
non mais ils sont pas sortis madonna la
niçoise on va être là dit soit vous le
savez bon il ya valérie benaïm et amara
valeriya jean michel théry ce sont les
pires
la série nous présentait alors je vais
vous dire il est peut-être chiant mais
les pas menteur gérard louvin soir voilà
une présentation normal voyons la suite
du côté des ventes à l'airé peut-être
chiant mais les pas menteur
c'est beau bravo les filles la gestion
je suis pas d'accord d'accord je viens
d'y aller gérard tout sauf science est
un monsieur gérard reste toujours digne
même quand on le prend par surprise par
derrière
il est aussi très cultivé la semaine
dernière nous recevions la jolie elodie
frégé sur notre plateau ce qui a laissé
jean michel complètement de glace
m
quelle rage à gaza toujours dans la
demi-mesure michel donc la jolie elodie
porter une spectaculaire robe fourreau
verte
un peu comme com comment elle s'appelle
gérard tu peux m'aider
là
commentant rouge
déjà quand même le dessin animé voilà en
fait on le dit agir au sol à jessica
rabbi jacob et leur porte secours
mais jean rapide c'est aussi un homme
qui a vécu et qui nous régale tous les
jours de ces anecdotes gros bonheur de
thierry et jean michel
mais c'est pas raconté un rebelle
tu crois qu'ils ont encore pas les
années déjà
non
je vais vous raconter très bien et moi
j'aime toutes vos anecdotes venez à la
maison ce week-end ça va se régler dans
le valais minutes mais ils sont pas
sympas et que gérard lui qui est
toujours si aimable avec ses camarades
non malheureux partir et il ya la
monitrice elle se raser par jour sinon
elle avait une barbe comme ça c'est pas
une c'est parce que c'est un malade
parce que vous êtes trompé de magnéto
sait rien du tout c'est la régie bien
sûr il est 20 heures 13 ils sont bien
sûr avec leur blouson donc forcément
légal peuvent pas être au top non plus
bas ils font leur boulot là ils ont
leurs cailloux et le gars de la régie né
comme ça te va si on voit n'importe quoi
en disant je cite si vous l'avez ou si
vous l'avez pas l'expression sinon ils
n'ont ils sont calés l'ont donc là à
regarder et comme il est aimable avec
ses camarades
ah bah oui non peut pas nous enlever à
lomé nos jours je rien gérard car en
plus grâce à des anecdotes ils peuvent
faire ce qu'il préfère au monde des jeux
de mots pourris
là vous allez voir entre titi jean
michel et isabelle ça va être la féerie
du calembour avec des rires pas du tout
disproportionnée en plus et il ya la
monitrice elle se raser trois fois par
jour sinon elle avait une barbe comme ça
c'est pas une anecdote c'est un malheur
parce que cette femme était très
malheureuse à ces mariés c'est barbant
se raser plus que son mari non non je te
jure si à se raser pas comme ça mais
c'était pas mal
pour finir c'est un bonheur n'était pas
prêt à ça qu'on a pu
ouais c'est ça parce que c'est pire
qu'on croit parce que ce que je peux
faire c'est qu'isabelle rigole comme une
folle au jeu de mots de jean michel avec
à l'arrêt a compris ça je vais vous dire
la vérité
elle n'a rien entendu de skadar
jean-michel s'étaient vus servir de
politesse la preuve
j'ai vraiment sérieusement c'est quoi
leur
elle sait pas du tout quoi elle parle
mais elle fait semblant
ça va ça à part la danse isabelle aime
les jeux de mots il faut le savoir
quelle place dans toutes ses phrases
même si la plupart du temps ça passe
inaperçu
donc pour finir je vais vous montrer et
faire un petit retour sur un moment où
on parlait de the voice
ça ça a été diffusée dès qu'on dit quand
même mis knock c'est la première fois
qu'il est une star internationale et mis
knock vient parce qu'elle est très
copine avec mika est exactement
racontant que mika et fait venir qui les
mine basse a lancé c'est un beau casting
c'est un vrai beaucoup farmiga et j'ai
eu nicolas peut-être qu'il aurait mieux
valu que personne ne l'entend dari une
allocation à bah oui bien sûr et
allons-y
bonjour je m'appelle daniel lors d'une
de vos émissions j'ai vu christophe
carrière déguisé en madonna
c'était bizarre mais tout compte fait je
voulais dire qu'il est beaucoup plus
crédible en travelo quand critiques télé
108 c'est lui qui animera l'émission
demain c'est lui qui sera à la tête de
touche pas aux toits que crédit visa
français vainqueur 15 d'autres gens nus